et autres manifestations autorisées à
partir de la place de la bourse nadège
abderrazak vous êtes dans le cortège du
monde toujours autour de vous et
l'ambiance plus sereine
oui beaucoup plus sereine harris ils
sont plus d'un millier de gilet jaune a
participé à cette manifestation
autorisée déclarée à la préfecture de
police de paris elle a été déclarée elle
est autorisée cette manifestation et
pourtant les forces de l'ordre sont très
nombreuses elles encadrent ce
rassemblement devant derrière sur les
côtés c'est ce sont elles qui donnent le
rythme le tempo de cette manifestation
aujourd'hui alors voilà une
manifestation je le disais qu'ils elles
se déroulent dans le calme et la bonne
humeur des gis les jeunes qui est bien
reste toutefois déterminés à faire
entendre leurs revendications
à près de deux ans après le début de ce
mouvement de contestation les
revendications elles sont les mêmes que
depuis le 17 novembre 2018 hausse du
pouvoir d'achat mise en place du riquet
du référendum d'initiative citoyenne et
puis une demande pour plus de justice
fiscale sociale et environnementale
à cela s'ajoute évidemment une
contestation sur la crise la gestion du
gouvernement de la crise sanitaire liée
aux kobe de 19 et sur le scandale des
masques qui est bien avait fait défaut
tout début de la pandémie d'ailleurs
certains de ces manifestations ici ne
porte pas de masque
ils sont très nombreux à certes mais il
faut quand même le noter des
manifestations je disais donc il reste
déterminé à donner un nouveau souffle au
mouvement
je vous propose justement d'en écouter
quelques uns c'est vraiment un mouvement
solidaire
est ce que je trouve exceptionnel c'est
qu'il ya des gens qui ont des moyens qui
gagnent très bien leur vie et qui sont
là par solidarité et sa magnifique
mouvement malgré tout ce qu'on dit qui
pour vous voyez les gens ici vous
discuté il ya des profs et les
travailleurs il ya des patrons de tpe
il ya des retraités il ya de tout il ya
des étudiants des citoyens voilà on
n'est pas des casseurs on est des gens
respectueux pour la plupart et puis
l'événement de cette manifestation
c'était ce matin très tôt place de la
bourse de la participation de jean marie
bigard il est arrivé il a aussitôt été
conspué par ses gilet jaune qui estime
qu'il n'a plus sa place
dorénavant aux simples ce mouvement
jean-marie bigard l'humoriste qui s'est
désolidarisé cette semaine des propos
anti police de 1 jérôme rodriguez il a
été conspué sommet je cite de se barrer
et puis il a dû à s'exfiltrer 1
rapidement je vous propose l écoute m je
suis là pour dire que j'ai c'est le
shisha leader avec les jeunes bien sûr
je suis jamais désolidariser vigiles et
je fais des raids des propos de jean
bourdaillet on lui doit une belle partie
de cette mère de jérôme andrieu
n'attendez pas être conspué comme ça
quand je mérite pas ça je suis le plus
grand défenseur des gilet jaune
j'ai les couilles d'avoir gardé ce même
sentiment de bulles début est là
je comprends pas trop pourquoi c'est
comme ça et malgré les divisions inde et
gilet jaune qui restent à déterminer et
bien insuffler un nouveau
souffle à ce moment chez les jeunes
alors que vous le voyez derrière moi des
filets jaunes qu'hier et bien
constituaient les uns forces de l'ordre
ils sont régulièrement visés par des
slogans anti police slogans anti
hostiles également au nouveau ministre
de l'intérieur gérald darmanin malgré
tout cette manifestation elle se déroule
quand même dans le calme et la bonne
humeur aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup nadège abderrazak